Andrews with us in Los Angeles hi Andrew
how are you good how are you better than
I deserve what's up my question is about
my car lease payment it's around $3,200
a month and I'm trying to figure out if
I should continue leasing my car or just
pay them off and take the lock okay well
my calculator Smart Money Magazine and
many other financial experts say leasing
a car is by far the most expensive way
to operate a vehicle over the long term
and so for the next 20 years
how are you going to handle the vehicle
that you want to drive if you want to do
what the typical millionaire does in
order to become millionaire status then
you would not least your car you would
drive a two-year-old or older car and
you would pay cash for it and so that if
that is the conclusion then the answer
to your question becomes pretty obvious
and that is get rid of these leases
$3,200 in car payments what are you it's
our old dress code
gasps oh my gosh what is your income
dude phenomenal a month yeah a month
yeah are you are you pulling my leg no I
started a digital marketing company and
that's my pre-tax grant oh so you're
making three million dollars a year
almost four million dollars a year how
old are you 24 that's just insane
congratulations
if that's the truth I'm very proud of
you way to go well done and so here's
the thing yeah you need to be driving
that Rolls Royce that's a sweet ride and
in your situation that's what you want
I mean it's pocket change
but hey check what is it for our grand
yeah but my thing is when I did the math
I was like 58 out of the delivery but I
guess you already know you you already
lost the 58 thousand dude you're driving
a four hundred thousand dollar car when
you drove it off the lot
you lost 58 grand yeah when at least I
gave it back on the lease to what I
could resell it for after that fourteen
one term it's around a fifty six
thousand dollar difference
yeah but you that's the same thing as if
you financed it and you're making for me
yeah you're don't be financing cars just
yeah listen write a check and pay for
the car and smile while you're driving
it you've earned it gratulations I'm
very proud of you if all that's the
truth that's pretty bizarre stuff at 24
years old hey listen be real careful
okay let me tell you what I tell the
guys in the NFL when we're talking to
them NFL stands for not for long and
you're in the digital space and about
the only thing we're sure about the
digital space is whatever is cool today
in 24 months isn't going to be cool so I
don't know that I hope this income is
what you make for the rest of your life
but I don't know that you're in a very
volatile space so pretend like you're
not going to be making this money for a
long time and Bank a bunch of it invest
a bunch of it set it aside because you
don't want to be 34 and talk about the
good old days when you were 24 making
money you wanted though you want you
know let's make you into a billionaire
you're on your way if you keep making
this kind of money but pretend like
you're not going to keep making it
forever and for goodness sakes don't
spend it all that'll be your your deal
but can you afford a three or four
hundred thousand dollar car that's a
$4,000 car can you afford that making
four million dollars here yes you can it
blows my mind that you're 24 years old
and you can but you can't and I'm very
proud for you I'm very happy for you
congratulations hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and
out these other great clips from the
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh